a Chicago mom is speaking out after a
neighbor recently called police because
her young daughter was walking the
family dog unsupervised the neighbor in
Chicago's upscale North Shore suburb
reportedly told police the child was 5
or younger but Corey Wyden says when she
told police told police that her
daughter was actually 8 they said that
was fine and they left Child Services
was then called but not by the police
the family had to hire an attorney
before the case was closed
Wyden says she felt mom shamed something
similar happened to author Kim Brooks
she left her then 4 year old son in a
car with his iPad as she shopped for 5
minutes inside a store but Brooks didn't
realize a stranger recorded her child
alone and then called the police the
fallout from that moment caused Brooks
to take a deeper look into at why
today's parents deal with so much
criticism doubt and worry her new book
is small animals Parenthood in the age
of fear Kym Brooks good morning you
write in the book I felt as though I'd
been caught doing something very bad
explain what that's how this made you
feel as a mother you know I felt
everyone every mother wants to be the
best mother she can be and so when
someone suggests that you've done
something wrong it's it can be very
upsetting at the same time I didn't
really understand why what I had done
was wrong or dangerous and so that's why
I started researching and talking to
other women who had had similar things
happen to learn more about what the
actual risks are when it comes to giving
children independence and freedom you
talk in the book though about that
moment you were visiting your family in
Virginia and you went to a target to get
some headphones you were just gonna be
there for five minutes you factored in
the weather leaving the windows down
parking in the front of the store so
there must have been something telling
you that this may not be the greatest of
ideas right not really I mean I think
what was telling me that if anything was
just the fact that I live in a city and
so in the city I don't do things like
that because people steal cars there's
those issues but
I think what I was feeling was that this
was where I grew up and I had so many
memories of my own parents letting me
wait in a car for a few minutes while
they ran errands in the 80s and so it
didn't feel unsafe I mean obviously I
wanted to make sure that the conditions
were safe in terms of it not being hot
or anything like that yeah where is this
sense of anxiety come from that you
investigated in your book I think
there's there's sort of two things one
is that you know because we often see on
the news or on the internet stories of
you know terrible things happening to
children even if those things that we
see aren't very common or aren't
statistically likely we those give us a
sense that things are more dangerous
than they might actually be one
interesting statistic I found in writing
the book was it for example it would
actually take statistically on average
750,000 years for a child left in a
public space to be abducted or kidnapped
but that's something parents worry about
all the time right stranger danger
whereas 487 children on average are
injured or killed in just car accidents
every single day that's something we
don't think about a lot and so this
anxiety causes us to bubble-wrap our
children and what is the downside of
doing that making them live in this
world in which they can engage in
nothing that might cause them a paper
cut you know well the problem is that a
lot of what children actually need to
learn developmentally they have to learn
by doing some things on their own you
know by having some freedom independence
and independence things like resiliency
problem-solving just learning to sort of
navigate the world we we don't do these
things if if our parents or if adults
are doing everything for us the other
thing I learned that was really
interesting is that psychologists say
one of the things that actually makes
people happiest in the world is having
what they call an internal locus of
control which means that you as a person
have get to decide how you spend your
time what you do it's your time
when the psychologist told me this I
thought my god children must not be very
happy these days because the one thing
we don't give them is that opportunity
to decide what they do there what would
they do with their time what did you
learn about how mothers and fathers are
held to a different parenting standard
yeah I do think that this this sort of
thing does happen to fathers but what I
found is that I think a lot of times
when people see a father doing something
even if they don't approve of exactly
what they're doing there's a sense of
like well good for him you know for
being with the kids you know and
babysitting and giving mom a break I
actually talked to one woman Julie Kaler
who had a similar thing happened to her
and her husband had done almost the
identical thing a year before and you
know the cop who came to the scene was
just said you know well I know how it is
you know I know how hard it is to be
with the kids and I kind of let him let
him go the other problem is that you
know because in this country because
women still unfortunately do more than
their fair share of the childcare and
the domestic work anything that hurts
parents or makes things harder for
parents will disproportionately affect
women
well Kim Brooks you have raised a lot of
really interesting questions and brought
some research like thank you so much
thank you for small animals is available
now